Conor McGregor who is a you know
basically MMA Superstar uh he saw that
as a whole bunch of other people did
once it got community noted and he wrote
this she was abducted and of course he's
Irish she was abducted by an evil
terrorist organization what is with you
and your government and your paid for
media Affiliates constantly downplaying
SL attempting to repress horrific acts
that happened to Children you are a
disgrace the day after a stabbing
children in Ireland not one paper had it
on their front cover we will not forget
now what of course Connor is referencing
you might not have seen this if you were
trying to get off the machines over the
weekend uh but an Algerian stabbed
several children in Ireland uh they're
trying to find out a little bit more
info on that at the moment but then
average Irish people not racist people
people who are sick of their country
being overrun and their borders uh not
being protected started getting upset as
one might when children are stabbed or
you know if it's happening in Israel
burned alive etc etc we've got a
headline here from NBC News riots erupt
in Dublin after young children are
stabbed police blamed farri agitators
for starting the violence after a small
group of anti-immigrant protesters
arrived at the scene of the stabbing
attack and clashed with police so okay
you guys get it this is rinse and repeat
how does the media operate so uh an
immigrant this guy from Algeria stabs
these children then a few people show up
to the place where it happened and of
course they're now far right because
they're defending the children of their
country and they're the ones who got
into the clash with the police you guys
get it now I want to read you another
tweet this is from John Kavanaugh he's
an MMA uh coach I think he was he was
Conor's coach right for many years he
wrote so what should happen with with
this demented scumbag who attacked women
and kids today few years in jail at our
expense to get out and repeat needs to
be deported immediately and never
allowed back or just hang him there's no
fixing him Conor McGregor retweeted it
and he wrote torture and death so you
can see there is something escalating
right now I think people in light of
what happened in Israel are suddenly
looking at their borders looking at
their country seeing people call for
genocide having algerians stab their
children and a whole bunch of people are
going I think we have had enough yes we
are tolerant yes we are liberal yes we
love diversity and all of those things
but finally people are questioning woke
politics and they are getting over this
nonsense I want to read you another
tweet from Conor McGregor because he's
really he's the guy's be he's been
pretty redpilled for a while but it's
like it seems like it's happening in
real time right now he wrote us allows
not non-residents to vote visitors can
vote I can fly in now and register a
vote in the United State States
elections surely not however Ireland's
current government is proposing this a
disgrace a shame hang their heads in
shame hash for Ashling Ash for Ireland
he then tweeted out this Ireland we are
at War now another one I mean the guy
was really on it and and I I like when
decent people who are not particularly
political start getting involved right
this is how you actually bring culture
back Conor McGregor is loved by
literally millions of people across the
globe even if you're not an an MMA
person it's not it's not really my thing
but he is loved and respected by
millions of people because of his talent
in that ring right and then sometimes
push comes to shove and you better stand
up for things outside of that ring
outside of your area of expertise or
anything else so here's another tweet by
him he's referencing Michael Martin
who's a Minister of Foreign Affairs in
Ireland he wrote what are we doing SL
what have we done to ensure this
situation doesn't happen again Michael
since the heinous and horrific murder of
an Irish citizen in broad daylight at
the hands of a foreign criminal there
has been zero action response from the
three parties in power nothing at all
has been done yet what is the holdup you
have answered nothing here we need a
brand new task force founded in Ireland
with the sole objective of assessing and
monitoring all entrance that come into
Ireland and we need to we need a clean
sweep of those already here under false
pretenses or that have broke the law
here our country is at stake and we will
tolerate nothing less free travel around
Europe is not worth it to carry on with
this current system it is a failed
system announce this and correct it now
correct this or we are all finished the
straw has broken the camels back your
clock is ticking and let's keep going
with Connor McGregor because he he was
is really blowing up the Twitter he
wrote isn't that something oh so what
he's referencing here the guy that
you're going to see let me read the
Tweet below first liberal Irish
journalist who smears opponents of mass
immigration as far right uh gets sent on
his bike by locals after showing up to
the side of the stabbing so the guy that
you're seeing there he's just like this
local Lefty kind of woke journalist
who's been always going after the quote
unquote far right so now Connor was
commenting on that he wrote isn't that
something the absolute picture of weak
and feeble the most divisive of all is
the weak man one of the most horrific
crimes this nation has ever seen has
occurred we do not care anymore what you
sad cases have got to say in a war you
are nothing we are not backing down we
are only warming up there will be no
backing down until Real Change is
implemented for the safety of our nation
we are not losing any more of our women
and children to sick and twisted people
who should not even be in Ireland in the
first place call it what you want we do
not care may God help us all Ireland for
victory let's keep going with Connor
McGregor on Twitter deplorable we stand
with Irish businesses and of course what
he's referencing right down below is as
you know what does the left do what do
the wers do what do the uh illegal
immigrants do and all their antifa
comrades whenever anything happens
especially as it relates to race they
figure this is a good time to break into
Foot Locker and to other stores and
steal a whole bunch of stuff in the name
of tolerance and diversity or something
like
that